don't worry ready to be great I think
you look like I do think I win because I
out were people I'm a humongous believer
that ideas are [ __ ] and then executions
the game executing the way it always is
following the school business model is
gonna lead you to a place where you're
not going to win if I knew how to teach
self-awareness I probably quit right now
and do it because that's how I buy the
Jets this is the single greatest
generation of fake entrepreneurs of all
time at 23 you don't know everything
just yet in the old days we took our
opinion from three old white men that
owned all the media companies and told
you what to think there's a lot of
things I wish I was but but I just don't
lie to myself lying to yourself has held
back the far majority of this room from
bigger upside
for me I was always very self aware that
I was a good salesman and I loved the
action of selling stuff I grew up in my
dad's liquor store that he eventually
owned in New Jersey and then I grew my
dad's business from a three to a sixty
million dollar business in a five-year
window we are living through the single
biggest culture shift since the printing
press
all the stuff that's relevant then that
we talked about didn't even exist a
decade ago innovation is happening
quicker uber goes from idea to
completely disrupting the taxi black our
industry in thirty six months
in a 16 month period I grew a business
from three to sixty million dollars in
revenue on one very simple fact that
99.9% of these businesses in this room
do not follow which is I operated and
more importantly marketed in the year
that I actually lived in your biggest
advantage is that you're hungrier than
your competitor I mean if you want this
if you want bling bling if you want to
buy the Jets if you want to hit work
that's how you get there is no reason to
do [ __ ] you hate none promise me you
won't because you can lose just as much
money being happy as hell